J'avais peur non en fait j'étais terrifié
j'étais assis dans une voiture ma ceinture de sécurité
attachée en direction du festival
connu pour sa lumière son art son feu
feu quelque chose de si puissant si primitif
et il y avait du feu partout
autour de moi et je ne pouvais pas  s'échapper il était
terrifiant et je voulais lui
échapper mais un peu comme en ce moment mais oui
je veux vous parler un peu du
feu les différentes natures du feu le
viscéral l'innocent le puissant et
la révérence le feu viscéral est vraiment le
feu viscéral est  vivant, il parle directement
à ce cerveau de lézard que nous avons qui
dit combat ou fuite et pour moi c'était un
vol mais je ne pouvais pas il y a quelque chose à
propos du feu qui nous captive si vous
pensez au feu vous savez repensez à
quand vous vous êtes assis dedans  devant un feu de camp
ou un moment où vous vous détendez devant une
cheminée ou comme moi, vous êtes confronté
à des canons à feu de 300 pieds de haut en un
instant, tout disparaît et votre
perte dans la pureté de maintenant juste en ce que
je  nstant et tout semble
disparaître tout et ce qui me vient à l'
esprit, ce sont des réalisations que vous
n'aviez jamais faites avant votre esprit
et gémit et se détend et va dans
cet endroit Nate Smith un artiste de l'
Utah a décidé d'un petit morceau de feu qu'il a
allumé 400  des gallons d'essence
dedans c'était incroyable le feu la lumière
a explosé dans le ciel pour moi
c'était comme si une bombe atomique avait explosé
le feu tu l'as senti rouler de haut en bas sur
ton corps ton cerveau crie tu
sais dans ce primitif  langue pour courir
patiner pour vous sauver je me suis détourné
du feu j'avais bien peur Mille
zuv d'autres personnes se sont en fait penchés ils se sont
penchés pour capturer plus de ce feu
cette chaleur est-ce enroulé leurs corps
ils se sont penchés pour capter la chaleur le
lumière et un chaos pour moi c'était sur
place Épiphanie tout d'un coup j'ai vraiment
l'instinct qui m'a fait me
détourner du feu en fait changé en
un laid et joie le danger était toujours
là  le feu évidemment mais j'ai
pu vraiment profiter de la brûlure pour
pouvoir voir le comme j'ai vu les flammes aller
contre le ciel et j'ai senti le feu
rouler de haut en bas sur mon corps je pouvais je
pouvais prendre ce moment pour vraiment profiter de
ce qui se passait  la beauté la
créativité du
feu brûlant enfantin à bien des égards est
enfantine pensez à une jeune fille jouant
avec un cierge magique le rire et la joie
qu'elle a elle le fait tournoyer le long du ciel sombre
puis regarde el papa McKenna allez
c'est un  une gigantesque pieuvre mécanisée
crachant du feu de ses tentacules alors qu'elle
roule un fournisseur de tissu les gens affluent de
centaines de pieds autour pour venir à elle
ils le réclament ils rient ils
crient quand ils voient les différents
tentacules bouger et cracher du feu et vous pouvez
commencer à entendre le  pup pup pup des
Jets de propane, il vous rappelle à bien des
égards presque comme un jouet d'enfant un rassemblement de jouets d'enfant surdimensionné à remonter
incendié et lâché et vous voyez ses
tentacules bouger il glisse sur une playa
le rire  euh la joie que vous ressentez
c'est redevenir comme un enfant aussi cette
joie le sens d'un jeu à nouveau quand vous
voyez cette belle pieuvre avec ses
tentacules ondulant alors qu'elle glisse sur
une playa Toria c'est l'une des racines c'est
une de ces choses qui  reste vraiment
avec vous maintenant tire de nombreuses façons
aussi très ludique car un joue et explose
autour de vous l'un de mes favoris a
toujours été l'immolation de danse de danse alors
j'espère que vous connaissez le
jeu Dance Dance Revolution vous étiez des
gens dansez bien nous  a fait d'une manière complètement
différente, nous l'avons pris à un tout autre
niveau, nous avions quelqu'un dans une
combinaison de feu argenté essayant de reproduire des mouvements de danse
qu'ils voyaient projetés sur un écran s'ils
manquaient un pas, ils crachaient du feu
dans leur visage jusqu'à six pieds tout le
le chemin autour d'eux
dans votre visage
semble amusant, n'est-ce pas, il y a aussi un
réel pouvoir de tirer et rien ne le
capture plus que la mère serpent la mère serpent
est un serpent métallique de cent pieds
qui est enroulé autour de  protégez son
œuf enflammé il chevauche il bouge il
vous regarde mais vous contrôlez le pouvoir vous
avez le pouvoir du feu juste en appuyant sur
les boutons juste là ça se sent quand
vous voyez que nous sentons le pouvoir et vous
appuyez sur les boutons et vous voyez la lumière
se dresse à travers le ciel, cela vous donne cette
idée de ce que ce serait de
maîtriser réellement cet élément primitif cet outil
qui à un moment donné était là juste pour
effrayer puis pour protéger et existe maintenant
pour nous amuser ou réveiller grossièrement neuf
figures d'acier deux étages  chaque œil dans
différentes positions de prière, tous concentrés
sur un derrick de pétrole de 300 pieds de haut, il y a
différentes expressions, leurs mouvements
semblent vraiment montrer la louange la
dévotion la promesse en ce que nous en avons
quatre liés à la façon dont nous dépendons
du gaz naturel et alimentons le  incroyable
alignement de révérence que cela a avec
ces personnages priant cette grande et immense
tour dominante qui les domine, cela
évoque vraiment l'idée de nos
dîmes notre dépendance la faisant ressembler
à  e nous louons notre dépendance vis-à-vis
des ressources naturelles lorsque le derrick a
explosé comme une bombe nucléaire on aurait dit
que les personnages étaient tout d'un coup
libérés ils ont été libérés ils ont en fait
été libérés du feu le
feu peut aussi exprimer des émotions ils et
exprimer  une émotion telle que
l'appât ne peut pas vraiment être capturé par de
simples mots ou une forme de nombreuses façons, le feu
peut par exemple jusqu'à une seconde établir une
connexion et réellement créer
un mème qui peut vous exciter et réellement
vous influencer  Le piège de l'église était une
structure simple construite pour ressembler à une église,
elle était à une extrémité un peu comme une
souricière à l'ancienne où
quiconque passait par là pouvait sentir l'
incitation à s'engager, elle allait à l'intérieur pour en faire
partie et c'était à travers  le feu
que nous avons réellement pu le libérer
dans le ciel assombri le feu peut
nous libérer il peut nous libérer nous éloigner de
ces idées comme ces croyances que nous tenons
fermement si fermement que nous ne
pouvons même pas comprendre comment  beaucoup il
nous tient aussi il peut aussi brûler dans nos
esprits l'instance du feu peut
vous donner cette seconde, il est plus fort que
tout ce qu'il peut en un instant, vous pouvez en
fait avoir des moyens et des choses
brûlées et des croyances abandonner les croyances que vous
pouvez  il a eu de l'aide si serrée auparavant,
mais maintenant il se libère dans la flamme parfois
il y a des gens qui disent comment
pouvez-vous brûler les arts vous savez comment pouvez-
vous réellement regarder les arts tellement de choses y
vont qu'ils pleurent ils se sentent vraiment
découragés quand ils voient  les choses vont
s'effilocher mais c'est à travers le feu que nous sommes
tous libres en 2011, nous avons en fait lancé un
appel à travers le monde demandant aux artistes
de créer des effigies qui se
représentaient et représentaient leur région
en trois ans de notre programme artistique, nous avions
plus de 50  des groupes d'art répondent à notre appel en
construisant des structures en bois d'environ 20 pieds de
haut, ils représentaient leurs régions et
nous verrons comment ils se voyaient, c'était
tout d'un casier à homard du
Maine des oiseaux en vol de  Lituanie, une
hamsa d'Israël et même une chope
de bière de la République tchèque, ces
artistes ont travaillé dur pour créer ces
installations afin qu'elles se
représentent vraiment et lorsqu'elles
brûlent toutes en même temps
contre le ciel assombri, vous pouviez entendre
le rugissement du  l'excitation la joie telle qu'elle
résonne dans Black Rock City pour
certains qui ne sont pas habitués à brûler l'art,
cela peut sembler un peu traumatisant vous avez
passé tant de temps, tant d'efforts, tant
d'argent pour construire cette effigie
qui est le coup d'un  la torche peut
disparaître, certains pensent que cela
peut en fait réduire son impact en tant
qu'importance qu'elle a sur nous, mais en
réalité, le temps où les flammes
vont et viennent dans le ciel nocturne et cela
reflète les yeux et les corps
des personnes qui arrivent à  faire partie de cette
brûlure, ils peuvent être inspirés et
influencés par des souvenirs qui n'ont peut-être
jamais existé avant que certaines personnes pleurent
certaines personnes pleurent vraiment quand elles voient l'
art  aller quelque chose de si beau
disparaître pendant que d'autres rient joyeusement
je ne peux pas vous dire combien de fois on m'a
demandé comment pouvez-vous brûler l'homme nous
disons que nous les brûlons pour que nous puissions les
reconstruire l'année prochaine révérence
enfin il y a une révérence à tirer c'est
l'un de ces éléments les plus primordiaux à l'
origine Cavin s'est blotti autour de lui pour se
protéger et ceux d'autres cultures
et communautés les prennent en fait
devant eux et les envoient dans un
bûcher funéraire pour nous le temple est l'
endroit le plus sacré de playa c'est un endroit
où les gens apportent  des objets précieux pour les
êtres chers capturant des souvenirs l'émotion le
mettant dans le temple
dimanche soir quand tout
s'enflamme nous sommes libérés c'est un
moment solennel c'est un moment presque
indescriptible à quel point il
peut être émotif c'est l'un des commis et le plus
des moments puissants sur playa ont
commencé à brûler au Nevada, mais ses
flammes ont en fait traversé le
monde entier et chaque année des événements liés à plus
de 60 chaque année au  le coeur est le
feu je vous invite à embrasser votre peur
pour embrasser le feu car en
embrassant cette peur vous vous libérez
vous êtes libéré venez brûler avec nous
monsieur